outside the airport in Addis Ababa the
significance of this moment is
impossible to ignore
Kasai hailu and most of these families
have lived in limbo for months
I lived here apart from my husband and
child who I love I came here for my
daughter's examination and suddenly got
stuck when I heard about the news of the
flight I fell to the ground and cried
some nuts some left to see family others
for the birth of a grandchild
they plan to return to tigray in a week
or two but in November 2020 war broke
out Communications and flights were
suddenly impossible
I'm extremely excited that I'm going to
see my sister and my dad I don't even
know what to say
fighting began after the federal
government accused the tigray people's
Liberation Front Of attacking an army
base outside meccalay the two-year
conflict has killed thousands of people
and displaced Millions
a peace agreement was signed in November
it includes the restoration of services
to tigray and the resumption of flights
is the latest in that process
travel agents say the first flight was
fully booked within hours of the
announcement
it comes after a high-level government
delegation visited rebel-held areas on
Monday they were there to work on
implementing the African Union brokered
peace deal under the deal the tplf
fighters must disarm and allow Security
Forces to take control
Eritrean forces will leave the region
what we have seen so far is uh
essentially an improvement in relations
between the government in the dry and
the Ethiopian federal government uh but
broader issues particularly the
relationship between amhara integrands
remain unadvest and then so far the
negotiation has been going through the
federal government but it might be a
necessary that the amhara and the guy
governments directly engage each other
to address that
but on the runway in mckele the politics
and broader conflict are at least
temporarily forgotten
foreign
families are reunited no one expected to
be gone this long and the shock won't be
easily forgotten
months of work remains to ensure the
region doesn't slide back into conflict
but at least now they're finally home
Alexandra Byers Al Jazeera